There's a lot to think about
when starting a company.
And it can often feel overwhelming.
We talk to successful founders about
the traits needed to build a startup.
Let's hear from them now.
>> Now I tend to be very,
aggressive, in terms like,
when I want to you know get things done,
I'll get them done.
>> Yeah.
>> I also tend to be impatient in a way,
so
it's hard as being impatient,
is hard on me, right?
But sometimes,
it just helps me get stuff done.
In terms of Kowshik and I, we get along
very well that we're both that way.
And we get the gratification from
seeing or building stuff in our hand.
>> Hm.
Yeah.
It's getting an actual product.
>> Yeah.
>> And seeing that and
giving it to users.
>> Mm-hm.
It's amazing feeling to just be able to
draw these wire frames, and then a week
later you see it live in the app store.
>> So what's a skill that you
feel like entrepreneurs must have
before they start building a company or
a product?
>> Not sure if it's a skill
that they must have but
something that I've learned over time-
>> Yeah.
>> That really helps me understand
better about what startups are like and
how to operate them,
is that when I first began we
thought that failure is everything.
This one idea that I have needs
to be executed perfectly and
you succeed, otherwise a failure.
So at one point when we're doing this
paper swipe app model, and we're
getting them to lots of users, I think
I had this idea that if we switch or
if we pivot, then it's a failure and
I have failed.
And it's very hard to accept.
But if you think about it
in a different way where,
like if you're doing experimentation,
it's kind of like a science project
where you're trying to validate some of
the assumptions that you have given
some of the resources you have.
Now, if you think about it that way,
it was great experimentation,
where we realized that like even
though we tried all of these things,
it did not work, so
it must be the idea not the execution.
So, these days, what we do is
that if you have an idea or
you have a goal, we will come up
with some of these experimentation,
like experiment one, two,
three, and we'll try them out.
And really track the metrics
to make the judgement call on.
Instead of taking it as like,
oh it's my idea and
my dream, I need to make it happen,
if you consider as like, hey,
these are some of
the ideas that we'll try.
If they fail, that's okay,
we'll move on.
At the end of the day the worst thing
that can happen to us is that we fail
and we don't know exactly why we fail.
>> Hm.
>> Was it the idea or
was it our execution?
Knowing exactly why I failed is one of
the learning that will help us go to
the next one.
>> Yeah.
So failure is an option,
but you need to know why.
>> Right, exactly.
And it's best if you fail quickly.
>> Yeah.
>> The worst thing is to fail slowly and
painfully over years.
>> So it's just like Band-Aid,
rip it off and get it done.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
[LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH]